good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and they a CP were going to be
studying today is SCP 1341 object class
Euclid special containment procedures as
CP 1341 is to be held in a containment
locker located on the grounds of site 77
this chamber is to have two guards
monitoring it at all times
no arboreal objects are to be held in
the same area as SCP 1341 testing must
be conducted in a standalone structure
SCP 1341 cannot be brought into any
other building other than those
specifically constructed to house and
test it
[Music]
description SCP 1341 is a mason jar made
of red glass with the words jungle in a
jar stenciled on the lid with black
acrylic paint
when SCP 1341 is in an inactive state it
weighs approximately 480 grams removing
the lid when SCP 1341 is outside of an
enclosed space has no anomalous effect
if SCP 1341 s lid is removed while it is
indoors it will begin to exude soil from
the opening at 10 kilograms per minute
the soil will be continuously produced
until all available space in the room
and is contained within is filled with
this soil to a depth of at least 10
millimetres once the soil has reached
this depth several anomalous species of
plants will begin to grow plants
produced by a CP 1341 superficially
resemble species found in tropical
rainforests however DNA testing has
shown that these plants do not
correspond to any known species the
plants will continue to grow until they
have achieved maximum size the area will
allow they take a maximum of three days
to reach full maturity and once mature
are resistant to temperatures of up to 5
hundred degrees Celsius the epidermal
layer of these plants measures at an
average of seven point six on the mole
hardness scale they have been shown to
be resistant to all known types of
chemical defoliants when the maximum
amount of space the plants can take up
is filled several trees will begin to
grow fruits resembling fruits in the
genus
Durio two to three weeks after these
fruits begin to grow they will fall from
the trees and split open allowing
several juvenile organisms hereafter
known as SCP 1341 - - to emerge
instances of scp-1337 bipeds
and are not hostile unless provoked
instances of scp-1337 consistent with
those of wild chimpanzees when the
population of SCP 1341 - - has reached
between twenty and thirty the area
affected by a Seabee 1341 will expand to
fill the largest enclosed space possible
the root structure of the plants within
scp-1337 a artificial structure it has
been placed within new plans will begin
to grow from these root structures until
SCP 1341 has completely assimilated the
structure
addendum 1341 - one incident 1341 a
twenty initial experimentation on SCP
1341 was initiated the following
document was recovered from cycle after
the site did not make its monthly
scheduled radial contacts without post
delta this site was found to be
completely covered with plant growth
with all personnel stationed at the base
currently listed as missing in action
the following log is believed to have
been compiled by dr. boyd former lead
researcher of SCP 1341 day one we
started the experiment on phase three
today d0 981 was selected because of his
previous cooperation on other safe
objects we put the jar in the room we
were holding him in and let it do its
thing now we just wait and see what
happens
day 15 we finally entered phase 3 d09 a1
is behaving as expected and so has the
plant growth most of the chamber is
covered in vines and overgrowth and
several of the trees of begun sprouting
day 17 the test chamber has become
impossible to enter from the main
entrance so we can a hole in the ceiling
most of the test chamber feels like a
jungle now the zero 9a one doesn't
really talk anymore he just walks around
yanking up weeds his hands are pretty
bloody from doing it and he seems to be
running himself ragged I'm gonna
recommend the use of sedatives to make
sure he doesn't kill himself before we
wrap this thing up day 18 the test
chamber is impossible to enter by any
means both of our makeshift entrances
are completely overgrown however even
though we aren't feeding d09 a1 or
making him sleep he still seems to be
active
vital signs show he is stressed but
alive despite not having eaten anything
in the last three weeks
putting in a petition to end the
experiment to the director this week
anything between day 18 and day 20 is
illegible day 20
it appears that SCP 1340 ones effect is
beginning to spread outside the test
chamber the grounds have become
completely overgrown and anything we had
growing on site is growing out of
control I'm gonna send some agents into
the test chamber to retrieve SCP 1341
and terminate d0 981 if we don't stop
this now the whole site could be
overgrown in a matter of weeks day 25
the agents I sent never came back they
were in radio contact for a few days
though so at least it wasn't a
completely worthless endeavor
apparently the chamber has become even
more overgrown since the last time we
saw it they reported sounds of wildlife
coming from inside the chamber d0 981
was nowhere to be found the plant growth
out here has gotten a lot worse since we
sent them in I'm afraid we'll have to
evacuate the base as the continued rate
of plant growth will render it
inoperable within the week day 26
we can't leave I woke up this morning to
find that every door and window has been
overgrown by thick heavy vines none of
the equipment we tried using to break
through worked people are missing entire
sections of the base are impossible to
enter and Ernie went into the air ducts
and never came back
we gathered all the resources we had and
we're gonna try to find an alternate
means of escape tomorrow also we aren't
alone there are creatures in the foliage
they watch from the denser patches I
haven't been able to get a good look at
them but I know they're there
the reports said they weren't hostile
I hope they were right day 28 we
accidentally killed one today
Martin was trying to access the armory
and I guess it startled him we found his
body just outside the armory entrance
just completely mutilated and the smell
there was the smell of a dead body but
not just that there was this thick musky
odor nobody but Martin knew the access
codes to the armory so I guess that plan
is out the window I know they're out
there still they didn't want to harm us
before they definitely do now I hope God
gives me the strength to protect my
staff and get us out of this mess safely
day 30 I think I might be the last one
left we tried so hard to get out but it
got all of us Jana's fell in a pit and
it was filled with bamboo stakes
I still feel nauseas thinking over
Albert got stuck in some vines and we
couldn't get him out after about a David
grown over him completely I could still
hear him crying Lyra I don't know what
happened to Lyra all I know is once the
lights went out I never saw her again
d 0 9 a 1 is alive sometimes he talks
over the PA system he rants and raves
about how we let this happen
we let the base fall and become a pit of
weeds and depravity as he puts it
melodramatic bastard
I know that he knows where I am I'm not
going to play this game with him he
wants to play hunter but he's gonna be
sorely disappointed I'm gonna take
myself out first
and the remaining pages are blank on
that extremely happy note that about
does it for today thank you very much
for listening if indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
you